okay well thank you very much especially
thank you to the PI data team for having
me here
so can you hear me all right yeah no
it's like it's okay it's okay yeah so hi
I'm Robert and I work as a data
scientist for flix bus and usually what
I do there is optimization and machine
learning and in my spare time sometimes
I do similar stuff but with a slightly
different data and that's what I'm going
to talk about today some slightly
different data what I analyzed is a user
comments so comments that were placed by
some people add some articles they may
or may have not read online for
different news outlets and basically the
question that I'm trying to tackle here
is what can we learn from user comments
on use sites I guess most people would
say not much if any I mean have you read
them but I'm trying to tackle this
question not if we can draw some facts
or wisdom out of these but more from a
data science perspective so can we
uncover some some structures or some
patterns in the data and so I first
briefly will talk about the way I
actually scrape the data so where I got
it from and how much actually it is and
then the main part of this talk will be
about dr. vac so like this neural net
our own network method for word
embeddings and of course I'll actually
start with words of AK which is the
basis for dr. Beck and in the very end
we'll briefly also touch some supervised
machine learning actually on the output
or on the document embeddings of the
doctor VEX Network okay so and these are
the three new sites where I gather the
data from so decide Spiegel Online and
focus and so there's an international
audience here but I guess there's some
people from Germany as well so who's
familiar with that with these new sites
some some oh it's actually ok that's
that's plenty and that's good because
actually when I looked at the data I had
some working hypothesis in mind which
kind of looks like this so because I'm
in this under Halle the
yeah undoubtely did it there's a there's
a gradient in quality in any articles
themselves so I thought there might
actually also be a gradient in the news
or comments so like some slightly
smarter comments made on site online and
like all the hatred and racism planning
up at focus so it will later on take a
look at whether we find some evidence
for this hypothesis in the data but you
have to bear with me until the very end
of my talk and okay let's first talk
about how I gather the data so this is
the screenshot of like the comments
section of each site and it'll basically
look like this so people can put their
comments there and what is nice about
that though is if you look into the HTML
source code then actually the common pop
out in the source code which is super
nice because then you can use something
like the request library
hi Alex MLG basically just parse the
HTML source code and then you can gather
and get the comments just right out of
the source code and I did those so I
gather quite a lot of user comments so
about two hundred eighty thousand from
Spiegel Online 170,000 from sites and
roughly 50 thousand from focus and they
were written for articles between
January 2014 and June 2016 so roughly a
year ago okay and so of course I did
some very very brief pre-processing of
the data for this I use the natural
language toolkit and and I didn't do
much for pre-processing so these are
three actual comments and how they how
they look like in the raw data and so
for instance and as I said it's a it's
German news site so of course the
comments will be in German but I try to
translate them as good as possible and
so for instance here is I just going to
read the top one from focus which
basically says something something
something teach unity and justice and
freedom for our German fatherland at our
schools and so I took these comments and
you only prefers the thing I did which
basically lower casing them and removing
punctuation that's it so no stemming or
whatever just putting them basically in
Tison lists and for now
and let's forget where these comments
actually come from so in the first
processing steps I don't care that the
first comment was actually placed on a
news article by focus let's just label
them with some individual labels so
let's say this is the first document
that second document and the other one
is the third document and so on so that
every document has a label but for now
we don't care
from which news site the user comment
actually stems from okay so then I have
this data and I thought okay I want to
do some cool stuff with this I'm just
going to throw it into a doctor vac
Network and which is like super cool
deep learning library for word
embeddings and text processing and then
some amazing stuff pops out at the other
end and actually what turns out I got
two things wrong with this so the first
thing is that is actually not deep
learning it says so on the Jenson page
so the library I used it says deep
learning but there's nothing deep about
it it's just three layers right there's
an input layer hidden layer and output
layer so it's more like a normal
artificial neural network and the other
thing I got wrong is the amazing stuff
doesn't pop out at the end it actually
squeezes out at the site and never mind
still there's amazing stuff happening
how that actually works I will talk
about that in a minute but let's assume
that we already have this amazing stuff
so what is this amazing stuff and this
amazing stuff for now let's focus also
on words of AK so because dr. Beck gives
us basically word embeddings and
document embedding its first but just
focus on words of X so the basis of talk
today so what is the amazing stuff that
we get here and so what will this will
give us some so called word embeddings
so basically this is vector
representations of words so for instance
let's say we have a train network on a
like diesel corpus like Wikipedia and
then we would for instance gather
something like this so we would get an N
dimensional data so here I just chose
four and since four is pretty bad to
draw I draw it just in two dimensions so
we have this vector representation for a
word let's say hamburger and then this
is some vector in the space but then
nice thing is we can do some operations
on it so first of all we can actually
compare it to other vectors so we would
for instance figure out that this is the
representation of the word cheese
burger which is very similar to about
hamburger so they encode some sort of
meaning and these two are quite similar
but they might be very different too and
this is now very subtle very different
to the word clicks plus and so this is
something nice about these vector
representations so we can actually
compute similarities among words and for
those who are actions it's in a master
basically what you usually do is this
cosine similarity which basically is dot
products divided by the product of the
norms of the vectors ok but that's not
the only thing you can do with this
actually you can also do mathematical
operations and probably you've seen this
example a lot a lot because everyone
uses that so I have two two and so
actually you can add and subtract these
vectors so for instance we could use the
vector presentation for the word King
subtract the word man add the word woman
and what we get is the actual vector
representation for the word Queen this
is super nice I mean like this is
amazing stuff that pops out of these
networks okay so let's quickly look at
it how it actually works
and so basically what a words evacs
Network done is learning or to predict
words from given context right give me a
context of words and I predict you what
is the most likely word that occurs in
this context and and for now I'll let's
let's look at the the network so
basically and for now let's say the
context is very simple and the only
thing we use as the context is basically
preaches a precessing word so what is
the first word given the first route
what's going to be the second word this
is basically what we're going to train
the network on so this is how the simple
version of a word svet network looks
like so if you look at the input layer
and this is usually fairly big right
because the input layer has one neuron
for each and every unique words that you
have in your data set in your corpus so
for instance the the little cellar at
the very top with x1 might encode the
word unity its neighboring your room
might encode the word justice and the
next one freedom and so on and so forth
like this middle feller and so we have
an input neuron for
never unique word in our data set and if
you look at the output layer here on the
right hand side it's the very same
encoding so basically the same words
that appear on the input layer also
appear on the output layer so the first
neuron might encode the word unity the
second one the word justice and so on
and so forth
okay so what we now train the network on
is making predictions so what is the
most likely word giving a particular
context and as I said as context let's
say the only thing we care about the
first word and so if we would train this
network it would work kind of like this
so we have this word pair Irish guides
and wouldn't so basically unity end and
and what we train the network on is we
would use unity as an input and because
every every one of these fellows encodes
for one particular word in our corpus
the input vector is basically just a
single one for this x1 this little
fellow that encodes unity and zero for
the rest so we would put that into the
network then propagated through the
network to do a hidden layer up to the
output layer then some mathematical
gibberish happens in between and we get
out some output vector and if this is
our first pair of training data so the
first pair of words that we have unity N
and then basically what we'd get is just
random gibberish but what you can do now
is actually compare this random
gibberish to the actual target value
that we try to predict because we can
compare now this output with the actual
target vector and because we're training
on pairs the target was actually the
word and right so the target is as you
can see on the right-hand side just a
bunch of zeros and a single one for this
output neuron that encodes the word and
and now we can compare these two value
of these two vectors compute some error
measure and then propagate the error
back to the network and adjust these
weight matrices which are part of the
intricate mathematical operations that
happen in the middle such that the
output vector resembles more the target
vector and we could do this back and
forth back and forth now with our entire
training data so the next
pair we were trained on would be the
word n and the target would be justice
and we would basically do a couple of
sweeps through our entire training set
so all the all the documents all the
user comments that we have and train the
network we would always adjust the
weights in order to make the target
vector and the output make the output
vector more look-alike so after training
the network what do we get okay so let's
say we now did several sweeps through
our training data and we have a trained
network and if we now put in again the
word n for example we chuck it in here
so this is now the actual mathematical
operation so we have like this linear
operation where we multiply the input
vector with this weight matrix and then
there's another linear operation and on
top of that there's a nonlinear
operation called softmax but what is the
security details but what it actually
gives us is the probability of another
word given the first word so here it
would tell us okay what is the
probability for instance for the word
justice given the word end right so it's
like 10% here after training freedom
it's also 10% hand is less likely so
it's 5% in and that's that right so this
is AI now we have a train Network thing
is so where's the word embeddings now so
if you remember I told you that the
actual amazing stuff doesn't come out at
the back where we get this probability
descriptions but actually it squeezes
out that site so if we look at this
weight matrix this is actually where the
word embeddings can be found so this
weight matrix has as many rows as we
have unique words and this means for
each and every words like X 1 2 X V we
have the corresponding word vector now
in in this matrix so we could just for
instance look up the case row which
would be the vert vector for the word n
and we would get our vector
representation and I mean in the
examples I used before that with four
dimensions but usually you choose
something between 100 and 300 which is
also the number of hidden nodes in your
network okay so this was like words of
AK in a nutshell
and a very simple version the actual
thing is slightly different our site is
slightly more complex but it's actually
pretty much doing the same thing because
so far our context was just like the
preceding word what's the probability of
the following word what you actually do
is you train on a more broader context
so for instance what we actually want to
do for instance is something like I want
to predict the word and given the
context of and just as freedom and for
but it's basically the same thing so we
just put the context at one end of the
network and we get try to predict the
middle word so to say on the other end
and still the same thing holds so we can
look at the word factors in these
matrices okay so this was word to vac
now let's make another step and look at
dr. Beck and actually the step from
words to vector dr. Becker's is rather
small and so now we have word embeddings
so we have vector of presentation for
words what we're after is actually
vector representation for entire
documents and these can be arbitrary
complex so in our case this is user
comments but it's not limited to that so
it could be for instance entire books so
we could have for example I don't know
like a train network on like literature
and then we would for instance figure
out that for example Alice in Wonderland
the book is pretty similar to through
the looking-glass but which is very
different to the vector representation
of that capita by Carmack so so how do
we now make the step from words of AK to
dr. vac as I said the step is actually
pretty tiny so it's almost the same
network as before so we're going to
train the network on let's have a given
context please predict the word in the
middle and the only thing we now add is
we have the context plus document Tech
right so we have the context and the
document Tech on the left hand side at
the input and just the prediction of a
word as an output so so because that
this was the very first user comment and
which had the doc document labeled doc
one this is basically the input then so
we want to predict the word and given
the word justice and freedom and given
the docume
Tech number one and the beauty is then
of course there's again a weight matrix
we can look up the case element in this
matrix to get the vector embeddings for
a particular document the case document
and and that's the nice thing so we have
now these document embeddings but also
we have the word embeddings for free so
we get them too so basically this gives
those two things at the same time
document and word embeddings okay so
this was like a very brief and quick
overview of how dr. Beck works and now
let's actually look at what comes out if
I use the user comments that I scraped
on these online news sources and if I
train a dr. vac Network of course for
that I use the the amazing
Jennsen library super-nice where they
have a pretty pretty nice implementation
for python and so I used all user
comments struck them through the network
a couple of E+ it ran for a couple of
hours and then I had my document and
word embeddings so let's first look at
the results first let's look at the
actual word embeddings we get out so I
first checked if my network actually
picked up something meaningful or if the
whole computation time was just
basically just producing garbage and so
the first thing I looked at okay so and
now we can ask of course the network for
the word embeddings and we can ask the
network what do you think is the most
similar word for instance to the word
car right so we look at the the word
embedding that is the closest to the
work vector of car and the network
response okay so what I think is the
most similar to car is actually awesome
a while that's very nice so this makes
sense so car ultimate it's very related
and here in brackets to see the actual
cosine similarity which ranges from
minus one to one where one is like
perfect alignment order or perfect
similarity okay so car autumn all right
that makes sense but again we're looking
here at user comments so let's ask a
little bit more nasty questions right so
dear beloved doctor VAX
what is the most similar to fake news
right
germán actually fake news as a single
where new gun classes so that's why it
works here and this is what it spits out
so it thinks the most similar words of
fake news is actually good Minj right so
I translated this do-gooder so to this
diminishing term for people who actually
think it would be very nice if we are
kind to each other instead of [ __ ]
and so super nice and of course you can
also look at more results so a call
second is the poutine fresh daya so
which I translate at Putin's disciple
right and on third place its conspiracy
theory okay and we can look at more so
because as I said the only
pre-processing I did with lower casing
everything and just removing punctuation
so basically abbreviations are basically
words to that thing
so NPD that's a German horrid a horrible
German party that's like the new Nazi
Party so we can still ask Network what
do you think is the closest matching
words to NPD and it's CDU so that says
this is a German Christian Democratic
Party close second is actually the CSU
which is they have a very impart and and
that this is a bit odd but I mean this
is numerix and maybe actually it's true
a third place is the FIFA
okay let's move on so this was so far
regarding similarities as I said what's
the most amazing stuff you can do is
actually doing mathematical operations
like addition and subtraction of vectors
so for instance what do you think is
brexit - england plus greece so if you
now thought Greg said I unfortunate to
disappoint you the actual the person's
want his hair cut however grexit is the
second closest one okay but still very
nice brexit - tinglin plus crease is
almost corrected okay so let's get nasty
again so what do you think is that its
air one so Hitler plus three teen is
there okay let's do one one final one
because I mean as I said this is like
the example everyone uses if you have a
decent data set so what do you think is
king
- man plus woman right in a decent data
set that's Queen no questions asked but
again we're talking about user comment
and it's angular so she said she's the
queen of Germany I'm not making this up
actually came out of his Network okay so
let's move on and spend the rest of the
time now doing machine learning because
so far we only looked at the word
embeddings that spun out of this network
and now let's look back at our initial
hypothesis and say okay give give me a
random comment um I want to tell you
from which news site it originated right
and so basically this is the pipeline
here so I start with the raw slightly
pre-process comment I chuck it into dr.
Beck I get the document vector out of it
then I take the document vector put it
into a machine learning classifier and
the machine learning classifier is
supposed to tell me where the comment
actually originated from so where it was
made so is that actually a sensible does
that task makes sense right it could be
super super hard and the truth is it is
a
very hard task because there because
most of the Commons are just one-liners
so something like this so it's clear
that these things would come is a
comment so and this could have
originated everywhere so it's actually a
very difficult task in this particular
case it actually came from the Skip site
but it like there's lots of these
one-liners for all for all of the new
sites so how good are we actually doing
so I used a linear classifier stochastic
gradient classifier form scikit-learn
obviously again as I said dr. vex
embeddings as inputs and outputs should
be the class label side chiffon focus
and and I didn't use my entire training
and my entire data set I used stratified
training and test sets so that I had the
equal amount of tests and training data
for for all classes for all of the three
classes so about 35,000 comments for
training and 15,000 comments for testing
so how good are we actually doing fairly
okay so the training accuracy is around
60% and the test accuracy so with novel
data it's roughly 50% which is okay I I
mean random guessing would be like 1/3
33% we can also look at more details
like what's the confusion matrix here so
in the training data this looks very
nice in the test data it's a bit more
messy because it classified like site as
sort of a default but still there's some
some pattern in there still we're doing
like 50 percent and as I told you it's
actually a hard task right okay so now
coming finally back to the hypothesis we
formulated in the beginning and in order
to look for evidence for this hypothesis
what we can do is actually ask now the
machine learning classifier what do you
think is the most prototypical comment
that represents best a particular class
so like what is the typical focus
comment what is the typical spawn
comment what is what have you learned
there so in and we do a little guessing
game you know so this is the best
representing one for one particular
class and you got to guess which class
that is so
really the English part which I try to
translate but it was really difficult
and so nor is it just too tight for
living things beyond man but ultimately
even for ourselves because it is less
anthropocentric as it implies the very
idea of light a very narrow idea of life
so this sort of like pseudo-intellectual
poetry originated any guesses yeah okay
so this is the best route so this is the
typical user common under a site news
article what so that's what the machine
learning classify things that's like
pure sight okay so it's next moving on
moving on next one so the manufacturer
doesn't get the money saved on an old
toaster
therefore the breaking point is placed
where even the expert needs the Select
saw so this is the more sensitive
comment actually saying that things
break on purpose so you can sell more
stuff like phones or here at salsa any
any guesses so that's the best
representing for which class nitrox it's
it's regal online oh yeah so this is
going to be easy now so so this is the
best representing and it reads these
misogynist Muslims understand only a
heart hand and have to be reported
immediately if they reside as refugees
here this is what Mrs America got us
with her open borders policy okay yeah
and I mean that you can you can go like
the top 20 top 30 and they all look like
that trust me but this is like enough of
that so so but this is basic in my talk
let me do like a short recap what we did
so I started with scraping comments from
HTML source codes from these three
different news outlets we used in these
data to Train doctor deck network on
these user comments that I scraped and
we uncovered some interesting semantic
relations such as this one and also then
we use the doctor veca and
as an input to a machine learning
classifier with some reasonable
performance so it could reasonably well
classify where it originated from and
actually if we look at the prototypical
examples no no doubt that this actually
holds holds here at this point so that's
that that thank you very much any
questions
hi thanks for the toggle it's really
great when you showed the training for
dr. Beck it seemed like the documents
and the word vectors live in the same
embedding space is that true does it
have any mail actually they're not
they're not you need some concatenation
or addition operation but that they have
two different weight matrices got okay
thanks
that was great um how come you to do
more Pro a pre-processing so removing
stop words or stemming motivation yeah
that's probably some some good idea to
do because that would reduce the like
basic vocabulary of by a lot but on the
other hand this is user comments so like
typos are an intricate thing of that so
if you would stem a ways of that stuff
you probably lose some signal in terms
of like people doing like arrows a lot
like there's like a shitload of errors
in the user and the user comments so but
yeah I could it's probably nice and try
that too nice presentation thank you so
I was I was having the question about
what kind of function did you use for
this who is who topic like how did you
how did you find which is the best
comment in that particular document I
just I just used all the training
documents put them into the classifier
and the one that was like the highest
rated for that class that was the
particular comment so the one that is
where the machine learning classifier is
most certain that this is part of that
class okay okay thanks
I think regarding the pre-processing and
the errors have you any idea how you
could encode punctuation because that
might be really reviewing for like sight
or focus yes yeah I thought so too
because they do use a lot of exclamation
marks that's that's true I've no idea I
mean the thing is if you leave them in
there
you're like the vocabulary explodes
right because it's difficult so I have I
can't give you an answer here if if you
have an idea please let me know
yeah welding majors tend engineer
features like counting the number of
commas per words or so actually not know
so I don't have any tests with base
lines so probably this classification
task can with standard methods pretty
much be improved like if you do tf-idf
plus a linear classifier or nonlinear
classifier you probably would get better
results I was just curious of how the
doctor deck works and if we can actually
also use the output of that as an input
to a machine learning classifier yeah
but there's probably tons of methods
that would outperform that by a large
margin
Thanks
thank you very much for the talk I just
wanted to ask you about dr. vac so in
this process of converting the document
to vectors
you have all your documents that you
will do both training and testing on and
I was just wondering if there is a way
if for example now you have a new
comment could you convert this comment
somehow to to the vectors because it is
yet but okay yes you can and actually
that's a very good question because I
didn't use so the test set that I used
in the end for the performance
measurement and they weren't part
actually of the training set for the dr.
back so I try to separate these to the
very end so what you actually do is you
chuck in and like the whole context
different context in that document and
and you know the outputs and basically
what you do is a gradient descent and on
the weight matrix for this new document
and then you find basically the closest
representation due to this gradient
descent like eight or ten steps so yes
you can do use very novel data and to
compute document embeddings for that too
that's actually with again what I did
for the test set thank you
yeah I think so doc comments usually are
in the context of the articles do you
have also information about the articles
themselves like the headline or the text
and type I lay around release connection
I haven't looked at so it's actually I
have the data so I also I think it's
great the title and like a short
description of the article is for but I
haven't looked at that now and I mean
like some assumptions are you violated
because there's of course a correlation
between between comments made on the
same article because they at least they
try to respond sometimes to each other
but yeah but but I haven't looked at
that yes yeah when we would be fun to
generate the most that the focus has
respondent the site comment most
probable for some article or something
like that yeah so I try to randomly
select articles so not to get a bias by
topic but I mean like the topics covered
by these negative buddies use all it's a
slightly different so some of the
results might might stem from that yes
but I mean during training and testing I
try to make sure that all the comments
and the test said we're like we're from
articles or that haven't been used in
the training set sorry I didn't try to
mix these but still there might be some
signal in there
I thanks for the talk so my question is
are you planning on offering a Web API
for this awesome tool that you can that
you can use that you can use for
recommending users that might have
landed on the wrong new site and
unfortunately you know because I
contacted site and Spiegel about it but
they never responded so I wouldn't I
wouldn't publish that without their
permission so maybe I can ask them again
but the emails I send them just entered
the void so maybe they didn't like the
idea at all good because I mean they
don't they don't look so good in the
comment section
as you actually compared your results
here with a baseline now I have a simple
one so as I said probably tf-idf plus
classifier would outperform that a lot
but there's more like experimental
include that was not like scientific
rigor I mean the hypothesis formulated
is like not a very science e1
in the first place right but yeah it
would actually what we did in a hacker
day at six plus we try to use this exact
set up for classifying emails so when
people complain like the Wi-Fi don't
work or I lost something on the bus that
needs to be classified and sent to the
correct guys to actually handle that and
so we tried this and it sucked a lot in
comparison to tf-idf plus the support
vector machine play okay are there any
questions if not let's think wrote again
for wonderful
you